We have a diversity problem in terms of the housing,
type of housing that we deliver.
And we have delivered very traditional forms of housing,
families, kids, and,
but the stats
prove that we need different housing models.
I think one of the biggest growing, um,
demographics is the over 55, um,
middle aged ladies.
They're the ones that are struggling the most to find
appropriate forms of housing for them. Yeah.
So there's a calling out for,
um, being able to deliver,
um, appropriate forms of different types of housing.
But our planning systems and our planning,
um, methodologies have caught up.
So there's a problem there. Um,
so we need to be innovative.
We need to find ways in which to solve that problem
within the current planning framework.
Um, and that's a challenge.